[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here so this
is basically what i do on my laptop
right a lot of email a lot of text and
research based stuff a lot of google
docs
a lot of youtubing so that's watching
videos commenting on them and then all
the youtube studio stuff
then some light photo editing so i use
lightroom for that it's never more than
one image at a time it's making
adjustments and exporting pretty simple
there
and then a bunch of miscellaneous file
management you know downloading a bunch
of images editing documents signing pdfs
things like that i actually stopped
video editing on my laptop and it's nice
to have final cut pro and be able to
toss something together once in a while
in 1080p tops but for the videos you see
on this channel that are 8k with all the
transcoding and raw and everything i
refuse to put myself through rendering
on a laptop so i don't do that so
basically for my use it's pretty
non-intensive which means i can get away
with if i want to use mac os the
cheapest laptop apple makes
so
this new macbook air is the cheapest
laptop apple makes it is now more
expensive than the last one at 1200
baseline classic but this is the one so
this 2018 macbook air it isn't the
absolute miles ahead game changer that
blew everyone's mind when the first gen
came out but it's a good laptop still
just with a couple small shortcomings so
aesthetically it's still clearly an
apple laptop it looks just like there
are others full metal unibody build and
great overall build quality and hinge
weight and big generous track pad all
the things we know apple does well two
usb c ports on one side headphone jack
on the other the keyboard doesn't have
much travel but it's not the worst apple
keyboard which isn't saying much but
i've already gotten so used to the mushy
one on the new macbook pro so this one
actually feels fine it's a little bit
more clicky and it's still backlit which
is good and the speakers next to the
keyboard with the help of some magnet
paper we can see they're actually much
smaller than the grille might make them
seem but they are good speakers so
nothing wrong with that apple does
laptop speakers well but just overall
the whole thinness thing is kind of lost
like it's not a thick laptop by any
means but i've been using a 13 inch
macbook pro for a little while now and
this is not noticeably thinner or
noticeably lighter than that laptop if
you really want noticeably thin and
light you got to go get the tiny one
port 12 inch macbook which is both less
powerful and more expensive so it's kind
of a hard sell fun fact back to back on
a table the macbook air is thicker at
its thickest point than the 13-inch
macbook pro that i've already been using
so the wedge shape can make it feel a
little thinner but honestly it's not
really noticeably thin so don't buy the
macbook air this year for its thinness
it's weird to say but it's true so
beyond the build quality the display is
important to me and that was the biggest
downside of the original macbook air
which they still sell by the way
uh a low resolution with big thick
silver bezels and everything so that was
the biggest upgrade here in the new
macbook air we asked for it they made it
so it's now a 13-inch 2560 by 1440 ips
display thinner bezels black bezels big
time upgrade the one thing is at max
brightness it's not quite as bright as i
want to or i'm used to from the macbook
pro or even the surface laptop they all
seem to get brighter but i find myself
using the air at maxed out brightness
all the time and that'll naturally hit
the battery life a bit it's a solid b
plus battery life and a laptop still i'm
happy with it i'm getting the usual
seven to eight hours i normally get but
it's nothing too noteworthy but overall
i just wish the display would get a bit
brighter this facetime camera is
technically upgraded although every time
i look at one of these built-in webcams
on a laptop i'm always wondering why
doesn't anyone put a smartphone quality
camera
in a laptop no one is it too thin up
here at the top of the laptop i mean you
don't need the ois just the sensors
honestly this laptop should just have
the iphone's front facing camera and
face id of course nothing wrong with
touch id here it's fine it works it's
consistent but wouldn't face id be more
futuristic like the ipad pro or even
like windows hello i really would have
loved to have seen face id here i don't
want to turn this into some kind of rant
but it's just
super
not a big risk in any way right the the
display it's a big upgrade but now it's
it's fine the design it's not very
different from any other apple laptop
it's fine
the performance
it's fine the battery life
it's fine
apple didn't really take any risk with
this one not that they have to it's
actually really smart not to take any
risks in fact this is probably the
smartest no risk laptop they can make
they had their fan favorite macbook air
start to pile up requests like hey why
haven't you updated it with new
internals and a retina display so they
did exactly that they tossed in touch id
and uh that's about it this is what you
get the question becomes is it good
enough and i'd say barely i mean it's
1200 bucks and you can get more laptop
for less money if you're willing to move
to windows we all know this but a lot of
people for many reasons aren't about to
switch to windows and apple will gladly
sell this to those people i would have
loved to have seen apple make like an
eight nine hundred to a thousand dollar
laptop because that new lower price
would have been something to get excited
about but as of right now this isn't
that this is the super safe incremental
upgrade
which it's weird that that kind of
sounds like a bad thing it's not at all
it's just kind of the curse that apple
gets because you can't live up to the
hype of the incredibly revolutionary
first gen macbook air so it's fine and
you'll probably enjoy one if you're due
for a new laptop and this one fits your
budget and you want the cheapest mac os
laptop this one is good
but this all brings me back to why i
love the ipad pro so much this new ipad
pro which is 800 bucks
feels like a real purposeful modern
redesign because it is i enjoy using it
for more things the thin bezels are
awesome face id is here and that's great
the performance is incredible and it's
an even higher resolution and higher
refresh rate 120 hertz display it's an
amazing screen those are some real
things to get excited about but when it
comes to the ipad pro there's of course
still just one of those things that i
mentioned at the beginning
miscellaneous file management being a
big one that make it impossible for me
to replace my laptop with the ipad even
though i want to anyway for me i'm going
to keep my current laptop and my current
tablet i'm going to keep my 13-inch
macbook pro which has been handling
everything fine and i'm going to keep
using my ipad pro every chance i get and
i've also been trying the surface laptop
2 a lot more probably worth a video let
me know if you guys want to see
something on that
but as far as the macbook air goes i'm
going to keep waiting for that big
interesting upgrade maybe they
inevitably switch to those arm chips
maybe they have much thinner bezels and
face id maybe they actually take those
risks maybe they do 120 hertz display
something to get excited about but for
now this macbook air it's safe if it
fits the budget
then that'll do
either way until the next one thanks for
watching catch you guys later
peace